Perú afronta una crisis sanitaria por
una epidemia de dengue una de las más
severas de la historia del país y ha
obligado a lanzar campañas de fumigación
en la calle y hasta casa por casa sobre
todo en la región de piura en el noreste
del país considerado el epicentro del
brote en lo que va de 2023 la cantidad
de contagios se ha triplicado respecto
al 2022 registrando a 129.634 y ha
duplicado los fallecimientos alcanzando
los 191 según números del Ministerio de
salud peruano hemos tenido un número
alto de fallecidos eso se debe
fundamentalmente a la búsqueda tardía de
ayuda médica este
esos elementos resultan claves no sin
embargo los empleados de salud de los
hospitales peruanos dicen estar
desbordados y acusan no a tener los
recursos necesarios para asistir a todos
los ciudadanos enfermos dos cosas
importantes para dar una buena atención
de salud necesitamos infraestructura no
la tenemos y otro personal capacitado no
no tenemos tampoco la propagación del
dengue está obligando a tomar medidas de
emergencia el sector educativo es el más
golpeado en piura las clases se dictarán
de manera virtual hasta nuevo aviso
después de que 29.000 alumnos y 4.000
docentes contrajeran la enfermedad el
pasado 15 de mayo cuando los contagios
apenas eran en la mitad de los actuales
el Ministerio de salud había configurado
un comité de expertos para buscar
soluciones sin embargo Tres semanas
después fue disuelto intempestivamente
marcando el desconcierto ante una
situación que se torna cada vez más
compleja